what's up guys
so recently as the digital world is
taking over CDs and DVDs are becoming
almost obsolete and many of the new
computers and laptops are being built
don't even have an optical drive so how
do you read a DVD if you need to you
guys would go out and buy an optical
drive for like twenty dollars if they're
getting very cheap nowadays but it's
also another option that's less than
half the price of that if you guys have
an old laptop that you guys aren't using
anymore that has the DVD drive you can
actually take that and use that with
your new PC or laptop it's very easy to
take it out there's only a few screws
holding it together and wants to take it
out you only need to buy one cable to
connect it with your new PC or device
the cable that you would need is a seven
plus six SATA cable to USB cable you can
simply plug that in to your old computer
or laptops optical drive and plug the
USB in into your new device this allows
you to be able to read CDs and DVDs
whenever you need to and when you don't
need it you put it away easily it's just
taking out the USB so let's take a look
at a USB to SATA 6 pin cable tie you
something bought performs and I've said
it before it's really just plug and play
you plug in the SATA end to the DVD
Drive and you plug in USB into your
computer and then automatically it
starts working you can open it up for
the CD whatever is it you want maybe a
driver CD DVD good movie that you have
anything like that put it in and you can
play it
overall this is a cheap way to be able
to use the DVD drive if you guys don't
use it very much if you don't use it
very much this is a cheap way to just be
able to use it whenever you need to
I wouldn't recommend this to you guys if
you guys played all the DVDs and stuff
like that but if it's occasional maybe a
few times a month you guys should
definitely consider buying this well
guys that's all I have for this video if
you'd like to make sure to give me a
like and if you guys loved it and would
like to see more videos just like this
make sure to subscribe and hit that Bell
notification if you guys like this video
make sure to check out some of my other
videos and leave your thoughts down
below in the comments well that's it for
now guys and until the next video bye